I think it'll be very challenging if
energy prices stay at a high level they
will want what you and I would want
which is they will want to control their
own natural resources interestingly most
of the world in fact every country I can
think about Earth other than America
actually exploits its own resources for
I do think there's me continued pressure
and as we've just said I think there
will be a continued move to try to
control those resources but they're
still going to want to have co-investors
they're still going to want to have
technical expertise shared within the
industry so I don't think it will be
fully closed off I think that they will
control the majority interest in many
cases and importantly I think all of us
are going to be in the world in a world
together we're going to try to be
focusing on global climate change and
trying to figure out what are the right
energy resources to be using it ought to
strike all of us is a bit intriguing
that a number of exporting countries in
the Middle East want to actually build
nuclear facilities that's a bit
intriguing to me when our own country
tried to shut it down the only 20th
century technology energy was actually
shut down because it worked at Three
Mile Island now we're hoping that we can
restart it again lb it way way too late
in the meantime we burned a lot more
hydrocarbon fuels
there's definitely in the ship that
we're looking at the new reserves
because if you SAT here 30 years ago the
international l companies would have
been the primary people you would have
looked at for the additional production
because they actually control the number
of the oil reserves even in the ones
that are now controlled by national oil
companies and countries like Russia will
have much more direct say in what is
actually produced in terms of energy
conventional energy sources now I'm
talking about gas natural gas and oil
just like the Saudis have for the last
20 plus years being able to say more and
with what happens in their particular
arena and we're going to deal with that
doesn't mean the international oil
companies are going away it just means
that we're going to have much more
diversity I think not necessarily
smaller because if we if we increase
conventional fuel usage by some
twenty-five percent over the next 20
years that doesn't mean we're actually
going to have smaller producers it
actually means we may have more big
producers they just happen to be
national oil companies as you probably
know Exxon Mobil is not in the top oil
companies in the world